rockstar in recent years has severely
limited the number of games it wants to
release and has decided to only focus on
two specific titles because of this many
of its fan favorite classics have gone
without sequels for over a decade so
today i want to talk about two specific
games games that are timeless classics
and that are so unique there may never
be other games like it as always spoiler
warning ahead for both games as we'll be
talking about them in their entirety
without further ado let's get started
our first game is la noire it is a
detective action adventure game where
you play as former soldier turned
detective cole phelps and throughout the
game you'll get to experience his story
as he solves cases and confronts his
past el noir's claim to fame has always
been in its gameplay the majority of the
cases in this game will start the same
way you'll get a quick briefing from the
lead director about the case details and
then you and your partner will
investigate the crime scene trying to
figure out what happened after looking
through the crime scene you will then
follow any leads you may have discovered
which leads to you questioning witnesses
and other suspects after going from
place to place looking for clues and
finding answers you'll more than likely
find the culprits and arrest them
throughout these cases you'll also have
to engage in specific sequences like
chases fights and shootouts this is the
general gist of la noir's gameplay
you'll be doing this exact sort of loop
for about 95 of the game this however is
a double-edged sword as if you love this
gameplay then you'll love the game but
if you find it boring then it's probably
not the game for you as the gameplay
never changes this also extends to the
game's story all of these cases are
episodic meaning most of the time the
story will start and end within the case
as we start to get deeper into the game
this will change but for the majority of
the game especially in the beginning
it'll be more episodic just like with
the gameplay if you don't like this
style of storytelling it'll be hard to
get through this game on the other side
if you enjoy it then you'll have very
few complaints it's clear that due to
its consistent gameplay and storytelling
styles that eleanor was really trying to
target a specific audience and this is
probably why the game has received a
sort of cult following but what really
sets this game apart from all the others
was its facial animation while the
actual developers behind the game team
bondi created a new motion capture
technology called motion scan this with
the help of 32 cameras placed around the
actors allowed the tech to capture each
expression the actor makes the reason
this was created was that the player
could determine whether or not a suspect
is lying the most important part of the
game when it comes to the cases is
interviewing people and during these
interviews you can ask people a series
of questions and depending on their
answer you have to give them an
appropriate response the good cop option
is for when you believe someone is
telling the truth the bad cop option is
for when someone is lying but you have
no way to prove it and accuses for when
you do have the proof to prove them
wrong you can listen to how a person
speaks what specifically they say and
also look at the person's expressions to
determine if they're lying or not this
was such a unique gameplay mechanic and
one i've never seen replicated before
and the fact that this was made for a
game in 2011 is all the more impressive
we'll get into the cases a bit later but
besides these investigations the player
is also given the opportunity to partake
in side activities such as street crimes
and hunting collectibles except this is
where my issues start with la noire
despite the size of the map this is not
an open world game you will start a case
go around town looking for clues and
leads complete the case then immediately
go to the next one the only time you get
to do these activities is during the
cases already this sounds like a weird
decision as why would i stop an
investigation especially when all the
answers are starting to come together
just to do some petty street crimes the
game gives you no downtime between cases
and no reason to do them during the
cases making these not worth doing at
all there are 40 street crimes in the
game and all of them are more or less
the same stuff you do in the main cases
but without a story attached to them
those other parts of the cases where you
have to do shootouts brawls and chases
will all happen here they aren't
terrible by any means but given the fact
that the game provides no downtime in
between cases you have to do all of
these during the investigations and i'd
much rather do these cases as they have
an actual story behind them the
collectibles just like the street crimes
must be done during gameplay there are
over 200 collectibles in this game i
have the same opinion of these as i do
any game with collectibles and that if
there's no incentive to actually find
these then there's no point in adding it
in the game eleanor does at least
attempt to make them matter as you can
find film reels that have the names of
movies from the 40s and 50s on them and
the police badges can give you an outfit
if you collect them all but the only one
with actual value is the 13 newspapers
all of these connect and tell a separate
story we'll discuss in a minute and are
also found at all the crime scenes you
don't have to go out of your way to find
them going back to what i said this game
is not an open world game the only
markers on the map are landmarks hidden
vehicles and places you visited
throughout the current case there is
nothing the player can do to interact
with the world like going to clubs
hanging out with your partners or
participating in sporting activities i
don't mind that the developers decided
to go down this route with the game but
it makes the world feel like a waste of
time it probably took months or years to
make los angeles inside the game only
for a majority of it to not be seen i
couldn't name you a single notable place
on this map in the 20 hours it took to
beat it if you go into la noir thinking
it's an open world game you'll be very
displeased but if you go from case to
case doing all the investigations and
not really paying attention to anything
outside of them you'll have a much
better time speaking of the cases it's
probably a good time to finally talk
about them la noir with the inclusion of
the remastered edition has 26 cases the
player can solve cole will also move
through the different departments
throughout the game so the cases will
change after a while going from only
homicides to only arsons each of these
can take anywhere from 30 minutes to
over an hour to complete so you'll have
lots of time to not only enjoy the game
but the cases themselves it wouldn't
feel like a proper detective game if the
cases were only 10 minutes so the length
of each case is a nice happy medium
between being too short and too long all
the cases in the traffic department are
episodic but upon entering the homicide
division things will change the homicide
section of lanor is a sixth case
investigation that has to do with a
serial killer the first case is the red
lipstick murder arguably one of the best
cases in the game where upon entering
the crime scene we see a woman who is
naked bruised and has some writing on
her stomach cole's partner rusty claims
that this seems oddly familiar to the
black dahlia case he was previously
investigating however he further states
that it might just be a copycat trying
to throw people off his trail which is a
solid theory by the end of the case we
chase down the culprit alonso and throw
him in jail all seems well and good
until our next case is exactly the same
as before another naked woman who's been
strangled to death beaten then marked
with some red lipstick rusty as well as
a lot of other people within the police
department seem to think they aren't
connected and it's just a coincidence
this is a running theme in this game
where coal seems to be the only
competent detective in all of la as
after not only two but five cases with
similar crime scenes everyone still
claims it's just a coincidence now i'm
not sure if this plays into the politics
of la noir as it tries to highlight a
corrupt police force that's taking the
easy way out or just trying to create a
headline but it definitely was
aggravating by the end of the final case
we discovered that there is in fact a
serial killer which does not only mean
that this guy is incredibly dangerous as
he hasn't been caught yet but that also
means everyone we've previously accused
has been falsely convicted this is very
problematic and makes this case even
more important as there will be more
dead people and more people being
falsely accused of crimes they didn't
commit as long as this guy is still
alive this all ends at the final mission
where we have to go on a very large
scavenger hunt to find the killer cole
and some of the others in the department
have been trying to piece together all
these clues he's been leaving us and we
have to decipher these excerpts as they
translate to the landmarks on the map
this was incredibly difficult as once
again 95 percent of your attention is on
the cases and you probably won't
remember where the landmarks are or even
what they look like regardless cole and
rusty will make it to an old church
where they find the killer's room and
there is a bathtub coated in blood the
killer makes a run for it and we have to
chase him into a tunnel system and this
is by far the most terrifying part of
this whole game the map disappears in
here so you can't tell where he is the
corridors are tiny with no cover and
there are so many twists and turns you
could end up getting lost down here the
audio was also throwing me off as cole's
footsteps sounded like the killer so i
was on high alert and constantly
checking behind me it was such a
fantastic way to end this section of the
game and was a great example of what
could happen if la noir continued with a
multi-case story thankfully the rest of
the cases do continue into a multi-case
story but before we get into that i do
want to discuss something that does come
up in eleanor quite a bit and it's this
game's failure to address well failure
the beauty of not only this game but the
detective genre itself is that feeling
of uncertainty and it's this feeling
about whether or not you made the right
choice that is a staple of this genre
this isn't as prominent when lots of
evidence points to one person but as we
just saw all these clues and leads
pointed to specific people but none of
them were the killer however this
becomes very prevalent when you're
forced to choose between two people the
second case in the homicide department
called the golden butterfly was the
first case in the game where you had a
chance of failure this was the first
time we had to choose between two
suspects so at the very least there is a
50 50 chance we send the wrong person to
jail now obviously we discover later
that both options are wrong but at the
time we didn't know this it was such a
great idea except numerous times ellen
noir fails in this regard during the
golden butterfly case after bringing in
both suspects you interrogate both to
find out who the real killer is assuming
you fail both interviews and get many
responses wrong one of the suspects can
run out of the room and take off this
gives us a one star rating on our case
and captain donnelly the leader of the
homicide department will get extremely
angry at cole and rusty claiming that if
we screw up again we'll get demoted and
adds that we are to go back on the
streets and defeat petty criminals to
restore some of the credibility we lost
this sounds like an incredible idea
until not even two minutes later when we
start the next homicide case like it was
nothing while maybe in the games world
phelps and rusty had to earn their
credibility back we the player don't so
this just feels useless this could have
played into those street crimes before
and provide us with proper downtime to
complete these activities it would also
make the game a little harder is that
you have to actually be focused on the
investigation in the clues or you could
lose your job except this never happens
there was also another time this
happened in the advice department where
cole and his partner roy are told to
grab their uniforms as they're back on
the streets according to the wikipedia
for this game this will only happen if
you do a bad interview with candy the
lover of the suspect during the case so
you can get everything correct except
her questioning and still get a one-star
rating i would say this is a problem as
it's pretty idiotic an entire case can
fail from one specific part but at the
end of the day it doesn't matter as once
again we just go back to another case
immediately after to go even further you
can do an entire case and get all the
questions wrong and somehow catch the
criminal at the end there is no
uncertainty in this game as everything
that happens is out of your control this
wouldn't be a problem if this wasn't a
detective game a genre that is all about
the player finding clues and solving
puzzles to catch a killer elena war
isn't the only game to do this but the
reward of catching the killer and
knowing you made the right choice is
completely nullified once you realize
that your choices don't really matter
this however does bring up a good point
in that it's you have to meet this game
on its own terms rather than your own
the fun of eleanor is finding the clues
questioning witnesses and finding a
killer and while in the grand scheme of
things what you do doesn't actually
matter if you're playing the game like
this without a care in the world with
what you're doing you're playing the
game wrong so if you're willing to
overlook this and just play the game
like you're supposed to then you'll have
a good time but it does suck though that
this thought will always be on the
player's minds which might dampen their
experience after cole finds the serial
killer in the homicide department he'll
get promoted to advice which handles
drug related incidents the first case
started off really strong where it was
discovered that two people overdosed on
army issued morphine cole having a
military background had a lot of
knowledge on the subject and it was
really great to learn about morphine
through his dialogue the rest of the
department continues as normal except
the last case manifest destiny involves
the morphine again already i was hooked
as the advice department was similar to
the previous homicide department as now
there's an actual story but i never
expected it to be the story of the game
this once again will be the final
spoiler warning as it's hard to talk
about the rest of the game without
talking about its story so if this game
interests you in any way please click
off and go play it throughout l.a noir
there are three narratives being told
the story of cole phelps the flashbacks
of world war ii and the newspapers each
of these at the start will be its own
separate story but will eventually
intertwine at the end the story of cole
phelps is the first one we see and also
is the only one that makes sense at
first cole phelps was a soldier who
returned to la after world war ii he
would then need to seek employment so he
decided to become a police officer
throughout the game we will play as cole
and move up through the ranks going from
cop to detective then to moving through
the departments within the lapd like
traffic homicide and arson it's during
these cases workhole's personality truly
shines and we can tell right from the
start he wants to do what's right as he
believes it's his duty as someone a part
of the lapd to fight crime and catch the
bad guys the other stories are less
consistent initially and don't make a
whole lot of sense at the start the
world war ii flashbacks take us through
cole's time in world war ii how he rose
to the ranks how he commanded his units
and how he earned the silver star for
his bravery the third story revolves
around a dr fontaine and a student of
his named courtney sheldon courtney
wants to live a meaningful life and a be
a better person so he decides to help
out the soldiers returning from world
war ii he needs the help of dr fontaine
though as he is a licensed psychiatrist
the full story of la noir involves all
three of these narratives on the surface
la noir is about being a detective but
its actual story is about world war ii
and how the soldiers of the war have
adjusted to their new life the world war
ii flashbacks were not a story that was
created to give backstory to cole but to
every soldier in their unit coulson's
world war ii has always been by the book
he believes there is an order to how
things are done and they need to be
carried out without question however
cole wasn't exactly the best at being in
charge during the battle of sugarloaf he
took lots of men up to a hill to fight
the japanese but many were quickly
killed via ambush cole wanted to fall
back realizing this wasn't the plan he
had intended but no one agreed with his
decision he would then see his close
friend hank be blown to bits by an
explosive with cole being unharmed even
though he was only a few inches away as
the morning came the other soldiers
arrived on the hill to find cole in
complete shock from the explosion it was
also discovered that he was the sole
survivor of the fight and was awarded
the silver star for his bravery however
he feels unfit to carry this as he
earned this by being a coward the climax
of the war story ends when cole orders a
soldier with a flamethrower to bring the
inside of a cave while another officer
jack kelso orders him to just cover the
entrance the soldier listened to cole's
orders instead and torched the entire
cave until the unit realized that the
people inside weren't soldiers but just
civilians
what do we do lieutenant
jesus look at all the cats the god damn
screaming i need to think and how do you
expect to do that you [ __ ] maniac
they're burnt to a crit finish them off
do it humanely we are leaving this place
you do it belts get your [ __ ] hands
dirty
put these people out of their paint
now that's an order
[Music]
everyone out of here now
double time
you too good lieutenant phelps to an aid
station
weapon team will be blowing this place
in two minutes
everything that happened in here stays
in here do you hear me
i don't want to ever hear another word
about
after being shot cole would then be
honorably discharged and then start his
life as a police officer when he
returned home while this happened the
war was still obviously going on but
would end shortly after while on the
boat home the soldiers were talking
about how they were going to try to fit
back into society one claiming that he
fought and killed for his country just
to go back to being a dishwasher
mechanic many of them wanted new lives
as their outlook on life had changed
thanks to the war courtney thought it'd
be a great idea to take all the army
issued morphine they have on the boat
and distribute it to the people of la
they would not only be able to live
lavish lives but they wouldn't have to
return to their boring lives before the
war many of them agreed and he even got
dr fontaine to help with the offloading
of the product except dr fontaine had
other plans see this story is not just
about the soldiers from world war ii but
also the general public's opinion about
them being a soldier is a selfless act
that carries very little praise with it
this is shown in dr fontaine as he uses
the returning soldiers as a way to
embezzle money and commit fraud he and
many high-ranking people in la including
the chief of police the mayor and new
york times editor and a couple others
were all a part of this group that was
secretly going to make millions off the
backs of veterans the entire arson
department that cole gets demoted to is
all about uncovering this group's
secrets the group was planning on making
homes for returning soldiers so on the
surface it was a generous act but deeper
is where that conspiracy lies they first
needed to find the proper land to start
so they would buy people's old homes and
replace all those homes wooden brick
structures with movie prop versions of
the same material they would then use
the official documents they create to
cover up the fraudulent material and be
able to sell the houses for five times
as much money as they paid the only
problem is that some homeowners weren't
selling their houses no matter what they
were given as compensation so one of its
members started a fake contest within
his company in which all the winners
would be those who wouldn't sell their
house the plan was that while their
family was out celebrating their cruise
or vacation they would burn the house
down and take over the property rights
to do this fontaine would hire a man
named ira to burn them down and this is
where things get crazy ira is not only
the person who burnt down the houses but
was the soldier who burned down the cave
in the flashback and was the patient
courtney wanted dr fontaine to see as he
wanted his friends to get proper
treatment after the horrors they saw
during the war this is what i mean when
i said everything in this game connects
all these flashbacks crime scenes and
newspaper readings were all setting up a
story that would be in the main plot
towards the end of the game and that
story was remarkable and something i
haven't seen done this well in recent
memory if you're willing to get through
the first half of the game doing
episodic cases then you'll be presented
with one of the best stories gaming has
seen it's not a story that makes you
question your morals but it's one that
carefully dropped hints as the game went
on and eventually wrapped it all up at
the end it's one of those stories that
makes very little sense in the beginning
until it all comes together at the end
and that light bulb in your brain goes
off as you remember all the past
flashbacks and how everything connects
and it was such a wonderful experience
to wrap up la noir it's still one of the
best detective games in the industry and
i have yet to see it be surpassed by any
other game of its kind its graphics
while not the greatest looking are
completely overshadowed by the motion
capture of the actors allowing the game
to benefit from this both visually and
mechanically you become a real detective
thanks to this game allowing most
decisions to be done by the player
whether that's interviewing suspects or
finding clues at a crime scene it takes
you through the steps of being a
detective and let your own decisions
control the case for the most part even
the episodic episodes have wonderful
stories within them and this is further
helped by how much freedom the player is
given during the crime scene and
questioning phases as you're figuring
the case out on your own if there was
ever a detective game i would recommend
it would have to be la noire
our second and final game is bully which
is also an action adventure game but
unlike ellie nawar where you're a
detective you're instead a delinquent
who picks fights with anyone who looks
at him wrong you play as jimmy hopkins a
punk who just got dropped off at
bolworth academy because his mom is
going on a year-long honeymoon with her
new husband originally i thought this
story was going to revolve around jimmy
and how he's coping with his new
environment as i thought bolworth was
full of snobby rich kids who were above
petty brawlings until not even two
minutes later i saw someone get choked
out on the ground this school and even
this game is complete chaos and it's
definitely a game you don't need to take
too seriously as almost every line of
dialogue has some sort of joke involved
smashing
now tell me hopkins
is it true you said i was inbred
no because first cousins is legal my
friend legal yeah okay yeah and just
because my elder brother doesn't have a
chin and ended up in a lunatic asylum it
doesn't mean anything whatever tad your
family is your business don't lie jimmy
you said tad was probably a
hermaphrodite with that much inbreed
hermaphro what
don't act dumb you said his mom was also
legally his aunt that he probably had
webbed toes i don't
well just only on one foot this game
also heavily plays into the traditional
school stereotypes and uses these as a
way to poke fun at them early in the
game we get introduced to all the clicks
at the academy and all of them are
exactly what you would expect the nerds
are people who will occasionally talk to
you as if you were a character in
dungeons and dragons and the greasers
all look like the main cast from the
outsiders you won't be able to join any
of these clicks but you'll be able to
interact with all of them throughout the
game like i said this game is not meant
to be taken seriously and i think that's
one of bully's biggest strengths it has
this distinct charm to it that makes the
game so special to a lot of people as
you can't find a game like this anywhere
else it's comedy characters and missions
are a huge part of this game's strengths
and it's without a doubt some of the
best parts of the game one minute you're
training with a homeless man who lives
on campus then the next minute you're
chatting with gary about a halloween
prank who's just casually wearing a nazi
uniform genuinely you can't find a game
like this anymore things just keep
getting weirder and funnier and more
absurd every minute you play and it's
that last part that's important this
game really is absurd you get a variety
of equipment in this game and these
range from stink bombs and egg cartons
to firecrackers and slingshots all of
this can be used during combat so it
makes the fights that much more insane
when you realize you can chuck
firecrackers at people besides picking
fights with random students you can do a
variety of tasks and missions each
mission whether it's a side mission or
main mission is marked with a gold star
and these can range from pretty much
anything i actually enjoyed this a lot
as most of the time it's hard to tell
which mission is required as all of them
blend together for example throwing eggs
through ted's house and assisting mr
galloway with his drinking problem are
both main missions yet don't seem like
they would fit together in a storyline
some players might see this and then
become bored as they're either not
interested in the story as it's all over
the place or they're eagerly waiting to
do more story content but keep getting
put into side missions while the former
is true to some regard and we'll talk
about that later for the latter this
isn't a matter of concern as most
missions in this game are 5 to 10
minutes i completed all the story
missions and quite a few side missions
which roughly totaled to around 60 total
missions despite how lengthy that may
sound these missions didn't take long as
i beat the game in around 10 hours now
100 in the game is a different story
thanks to the game having lots of
collectibles but at least for the
missions you won't be spending dozens of
hours trying to get through the first
chapter and with how the modern gaming
market is now that sounds like a
blessing it's a game that you can play
for a couple hours a day or even a week
and by the time you finish the game
you'll feel like you've made actual
progress besides its missions there was
a lot involved in this gameplay loop and
that honestly surprised me given that
the setting is a school there are some
time constraints to keep note of morning
classes go from 9 to 11 30 and afternoon
classes go from 1 to 3 30. if you're
late to class the prefects patrolling
the school will bust you and force you
to attend class the game also has curfew
times as you weren't allowed to be in
the school past 7 and you have to be in
the dorm past 11. if you're violating
any of these rules you'll receive a sort
of wanted meter in the top right which
will cause the prefix to chase you down
if they spot you besides these
restrictions the player will also get
wanted for violence bullying and many
other things that violate the school's
rules these the first glance sound
rather annoying but i also found these
ideas to be rather smart these
violations not only make the missions
harder but also actively push the player
to attend school bulworth is an academy
after all and it wouldn't make much
sense for the player to not get punished
for skipping class for example when the
player enters chapter 2 the town of
bolworth is now accessible to them i
started my day by fighting some preppies
after gary took them off after this i
got to help a girl get front row seats
to a movie and then made my way to the
carnival where i watched a [ __ ] beat
up on a gnome this was during that gap
in the morning and afternoon where i had
classes so the police were actively
looking for me because i was skipping
class granted it's a lot easier to evade
them than the prefects on campus but
still i wasn't able to completely roam
the map carefree i then took the girl
from the movie out on a date and then
caught my pe teacher coming out of an
adult store not only does this reinforce
how much you can get done in such a
short amount of time as while in game
this lasted a whole day it was really
just 30 minutes but this also led to one
of the most stressful moments in this
game i ever had there is one final time
restriction this game has and it's at
2am where jimmy will collapse from
exhaustion and be forced to wake up the
next morning in his bed only once did i
ever stay out this late but the one time
i did i was racing against the clock
that pe teacher from earlier wanted me
to sneak into the girls dorm to get
their laundry the time i had arrived at
the school it was already 12 30 so i had
very little time left in the day to get
this done i started panicking as the
clock was moving faster than i had
anticipated so instead of sneaking i
sprinted through the halls and managed
to complete the mission by 1 40. i then
had to race to the dorm room and buy
some miracle i managed to make it in bed
by literally 1 59 am now i probably
hyped it up way more than i needed to
but it goes back to what i said about
the time constraints and how they make
these missions harder this sort of thing
doesn't happen all the time but for
something a bit more common you'll
sometimes be running around the school
after hours or even during class time so
while you need to go pick people's
lockers or go to certain parts of the
school to start a mission the prefects
are searching for you and trying to bust
you for being late constraints like this
especially when they're very aggressive
can be more a chore than an obstacle but
in this case i loved it not just the
timers but the other violations were
great and it made the game a bit more
challenging and when the game is more
challenging the more focused you are
because i was more focused while playing
the game i was actively paying attention
to it and appreciating everything it had
to offer a few minutes ago i talked
about the classes and those two have
their own mechanics involved in them
bully has 10 classes available in the
scholarship edition and each of them
have activities that closely resemble
the class english is about taking
specific letters and making words out of
them and music class is a rhythm game
each class has a specific threshold you
need to pass before it counts as a
passing grade so not only will the
activities themselves get harder but
you're expected to perform better as you
go through the classes these were really
fun even if some of them were incredibly
hard but after a while i just ignored
them once i started becoming more
accustomed to the game i started going
to class less and less because i was not
only able to avoid the prefix easier but
the rewards weren't as beneficial as i
had hoped art and chemistry are without
a doubt the most important classes as
chemistry provides you with your own
equipment in your room and you can use
this to create more firecrackers stink
bombs and itching powder while our class
increases your health when you make out
with other students some of the others
have their own personal uses like
photography granting the player a photo
album and the gym class increasing
accuracy with weapons but i never found
these to be as important as the game
made it out to be the other classes
however will only provide outfits and
are strictly there to give more
customization to the player i have no
issue with this as i'm always a fan of
customization but it started to get in
the way of the other classes i wanted to
take first what would have helped a lot
would have been the ability to skip the
rest of the day by sleeping in your bed
this game only lets you sleep past 7 pm
and there is no way to skip time so
assuming you only want to take those
classes that day you'll have to wait a
while to try again furthermore the game
only lets you save at journals and
nowhere else this can be slightly
inconvenient especially if it's a fair
distance away but the most frustrating
part is when the game bugs out
thankfully this only happened to me one
time but due to the missions being
really quick i was rifling through all
of chapter 3's missions this specific
mission right at the end of chapter 3 is
where you face off against jonny vincent
the leader of the greasers the game is
supposed to have johnny slam on the
ground and then have the cop show up
breaking up the fight the two will then
rush to this junkyard where they
actually duke it out except i was
unaware this was going to happen and i
assumed that we would fight right here
in the alleyway so while the game was
loading i was spamming the weapon wheel
so i could get the jump on him with my
firecrackers what happened was that i
landed on the skateboard and soft-locked
the game running in this game is caused
by pressing or holding the a button but
while holding the skateboard jimmy will
ride the board instead however i don't
think it requires an input on the player
as you can clearly see jimmy running in
the cutscene so the game must have
gotten the command that jimmy was
running and decided to use the
skateboard instead of just running like
normal which broke my game i wasn't able
to pause the game or do anything but
restart and thanks to that lack of auto
saves i had to do the entirety of
chapter 3 again this was the only major
bug i ever ran into during my playtime
which was nice but of course any loss of
progress is upsetting as for the
checkpoints it's not that i wish that
there was more i just wish the game
handled them a bit differently most
missions will not have checkpoints
meaning you need to do the whole mission
over again if you fail initially it's
not too big of a deal since most
missions can be completed in 5 to 10
minutes but what the game won't tell you
is that you have to go back to restart
the mission for example in the mission
preppies vandalize we find out that the
preps trophies have been stolen and we
need to find out who did it we then have
to go across town to visit the greasers
to make sure they weren't the ones who
started any trouble after learning it
wasn't them we check out an abandoned
warehouse south of our location and find
the culprits responsible for not only
the trophies but the rat outbreak on
campus everything was going well except
i forgot to read the mission objective
and didn't realize i needed to not get
caught while sneaking inside i figured
this wasn't a big deal and i would just
restart at the entrance of the warehouse
except i didn't and i had to restart the
whole mission and not only did i have to
restart but i had to start the mission
myself meaning i had to go all the way
back to the gym just to start the
mission then go all the way back to the
warehouse hoping i didn't get caught or
i'd have to do this all over again
sometimes though the missions do have
checkpoints but are placed in the most
bizarre spots which is later in the game
where we need to bust out johnny vincent
from the asylum in town to achieve this
we have to sneak into the asylum without
getting caught however there is a lot of
guards in here and if you're caught the
game will send you back to the most
recent checkpoint except it's not in the
asylum it's outside the front gate so
you have to go all the way around the
asylum and get over the fence just to
get inside the actual building so you
can have another try i'm grateful that
there is at least a checkpoint i don't
understand why it's so far back when
adding it right at the entrance would
have just been a much better choice
originally i was going to explain these
issues but then defend them by saying
how it's simply just a product of its
time as bully was released in 2006 when
games didn't have mechanics like this
until i realized this game was released
the same year as oblivion and gears of
war both of which either had auto saves
or vast checkpoints thus making this
argument redundant i'm not sure why
bully opted to go with this system as it
makes the game more tedious for
seemingly no reason speaking of things
that were poor implementations the last
thing we have to discuss is the story
bully's story is okay at best but it's
not the storyline itself that makes it
entertaining it's the characters the
characters as we discussed earlier are
extremely unique with different
personalities that is easy to spot them
at a glance so many times i would walk
around campus and see algae and
immediately know it was him not just
because of his visual design but because
of his unique personality meeting with
these characters who are cardboard
cutouts of specific stereotypes and then
seeing them be the brunt of jokes thanks
to that stereotype is great this even
relates to the characters who don't
belong in cliques like gary jimmy and
petey these three don't have a set
personality that are defined by the game
which means they're even more unique as
they don't conform to the general
population seeing these three interact
together is great as jimmy and gary get
into heated arguments and while one is
trying to top the other pd attempts to
settle the dispute except both jimmy and
gary will use this time to poke funipete
and then go right back to arguing again
as i said the game's characters are a
huge strength of this game but its
storyline does lack quite a bit during
chapter 1 gary mentions to jimmy how he
has a plan to take over the school and
he wants jimmy to join him jimmy
obviously doesn't care for this stuff
and just wants to be left alone but gary
always seems to convince him to help
this comes to an end in chapter 1 when
gary makes him fight russell because he
believes that jimmy hates him whether it
was intentional or not gary seems to
have created this narrative in his head
so that he has a reason to portray jimmy
at the end of the chapter after this
chapters 2 through 4 are all about
recruiting the other clicks so that you
have more power over gary this starts
with the preps then the greasers and
finally the nerds despite the praise i
gave the game about how it blends these
missions together so it's hard to tell
what missions are actually required or
not there is a downside to it two of
chapter two's missions are revolved
around you getting ingredients for edna
the campus cook and then taking pinkie
out on a date to the carnival neither of
these make any sense and don't further
the plot they're just simply required
missions the player must do for no
reason this occurs a couple times
through each chapter but by far the
worst part of this story is the lack of
gary in these chapters after gary
betrays jimmy in chapter 1 we see him
one time in the middle of chapter 2 and
then never again until the final mission
petey has more screen time than gary and
gary is the antagonist of the game i
don't see how that is possible it's
really upsetting as this decision made
the story feel so disconnected and
uninteresting gary himself was a great
villain and his ability to manipulate
people throughout the game was great as
it made jimmy's life harder but cutting
his screen time made his actual presence
in the game feel less important bully
was such a great game as its ability to
keep me invested in everything the game
had to offer was impressive and this was
due in part to its great attention to
humor its incredibly unique cast and its
gameplay mechanics that gave the player
a sense of urgency throughout the game
but to wrap up my final thoughts both of
these games are quite unique and
magnificent in their own ways it just
simply isn't possible to choose a better
game as they both fill specific niches
la noir is for those who enjoy detective
games with stellar story and wonderful
player involvement while bully is a
lighthearted game for when you need to
have a few laughs and it also comes with
a whole host of distinct characters with
great personalities and a variety of
missions that have different objectives
within each mission so nothing ever felt
boring or stagnant it's clear that each
game has garnered a cult following and
that's what makes this even harder to
talk about as not only will we probably
never experience a sequel to these games
we may never experience games like these
ever again
thank you all for watching today's video
if you enjoyed then be sure to leave a
like and subscribe if you're new well
these games were wonderful to play and i
highly recommend you give them a try if
you haven't already as always thank you
to my returning viewers for coming back
to another video and with that everyone
take care and goodbye
[Music]
you